magic they're shocking
but unfortunately they're not surprising
we released information even before
russia's invasion
showing that russia would engage in acts
of brutality against civilians included
including targeted killings of
dissidents and others they deemed a
threat to their occupation
and as the horrific images that have
emerged from buche have shown that's
exactly what they have done
we had already concluded that russia
committed war crimes in ukraine and the
information from bucha appears to show
further evidence of war crimes and as
the president said we will work with the
world to ensure there is full
accountability for these crimes
we are also working intensively with our
european allies on further sanctions
to raise the pressure and raise the cost
on putin and on russia
today i'd like to take a step back and
talk about where we are and where we
think we're going
russia launched its invasion of ukraine
more than a month ago when russia
started this war its initial aims were
to seize the capital of kiev replace the
zelinski government and take control of
much if not all of ukraine
russia believed that it could accomplish
these objectives swiftly and efficiently
but russia did not account for the
strength of the ukrainian military and
the ukrainian people
or the amount or effectiveness of
military assistance provided by the
united states and its allies and
partners
the ukrainian people backed resolutely
by the united states and other nations
have held firm
kiev and other cities still stand
the ukrainian military has performed
exceptionally well and many ukrainian
civilians have joined local militias in
addition to using non-violent means to
resist
vladimir putin also believed that the
west would not hold together in support
of ukraine
russia was surprised that president
biden in the united states were so
effective in rallying the world to
prepare for and respond to the invasion
and after president biden reinforced and
reinvigorated western unity at a series
of summits in brussels just 11 days ago
the russians have now realized that the
west will not break
at this juncture we believe that russia
is revising its war aims
russia is repositioning its forces to
concentrate its offensive operations in
eastern and parts of southern ukraine
rather than target most of the territory
all indications are that russia will
seek to surround and overwhelm ukrainian
forces in eastern ukraine
we anticipate that russian commanders
are now executing their redeployment
from northern ukraine to the region
around the donbass in eastern ukraine
russian forces are already well on their
way
of retreating from kiev to belarus as
russia likely
prepares to deploy dozens of additional
battalion tactical groups constituting
tens of thousands of soldiers to the
front line in ukraine's east
we assess russia will focus on defeating
ukrainian forces in the broader luhansk
and donetsk provinces
which encompasses significantly more
territory than russian proxies already
controlled before the new invasion began
in late february
russia could then use any tactical
successes it achieves to propagate a
narrative of progress and mask
or or try to
discount or downplay prior military
failures
in order to protect any territory it
seizes in the east we expect that russia
could potentially extend its force
projection and presence even deeper into
ukraine
beyond luhansk and donyet's provinces at
least that is their intention and their
plan
in the south
we also expect that russian military
forces will do what they can to try to
hold the city of kirsan to enable their
control of the water flow to crimea
and try to block mikhail so that
ukrainian forces cannot proceed to
retake her son
in the north russia will likely keep
pressure on kharkiv
this renewed ground offense in eastern
ukraine
moscow will likely continue to launch
air and missile strikes across the rest
of the country to cause military and
economic damage and frankly to cause
terror
including against cities like kiev
odessa kharkiv and levive
russia's goal in the end is to weaken
ukraine as much as possible
russia still has forces available to
outnumber ukraine's and russia is now
concentrating its military power on
fewer lines of attack
but this does not mean that russia will
succeed in the east so far
russia's military has struggled to
achieve its war aims while ukraine's
military has done an extraordinary and
courageous job demonstrating its will to
fight and putting its considerable
capabilities to use
the next stage of this conflict may very
well be protracted
we should be under no illusions that
russia will adjust its tactics
which have included and will likely
continue to include wanton and brazen
attacks on civilian targets
and while moscow may be interested now
in using military pressure to find a
political settlement
if this offensive in the east proves to
gain some traction russia could
regenerate forces for additional goals
including trying to gain control of yet
more territory within ukraine
now as the images from bucha so
powerfully reinforce
now is not the time for complacency
the ukrainians are defending their
homeland courageously and the united
states will continue to back them with
military assistance humanitarian aid and
economic support
we know that military assistance is
having a critical impact on this
conflict
ukrainians are effectively defending
themselves with u.s produced air defense
systems and anti-tank systems such as
stingers and javelins as well as radar
systems that give the ukrainians early
warning and target data
and multiple other forms of arms and
munitions
the administration is working around the
clock to fulfill ukraine's main security
assistance requests
delivering weapons from u.s stocks where
they are available and facilitating the
delivery of weapons by allies where
allied systems better suit ukraine's
needs
this is happening at what the pentagon
has described at an unprecedented pace
last friday we announced an additional
300 million dollars in security
assistance bringing the u.s commitment
to 1.65 billion dollars in weapons and
ammunition since russia's invasion and
2.3 billion dollars since the beginning
of the administration
the latest package includes
laser-guided rocket systems
puma unmanned aerial systems
armored high mobility multi-purpose
wheeled vehicles and more
material is arriving every single day
including today
from the united states and our allies
and partners and we will have further
announcements of additional military
assistance in the coming days
we are working with ukrainians as i said
to identify solutions to their priority
requests
in some cases that means sourcing
systems from other countries
because the u.s either doesn't have the
system or doesn't have a version that
could effectively be integrated into the
fight
sorts of systems like this include
longer range anti-aircraft systems
artillery systems and coastal defense
systems so let's take coastal defense
systems as an example
president biden went to brussels to talk
to key allies 11 days ago about how to
get coastal defense systems to ukraine
because there is not at the moment a
good u.s option
last week the uk announced at the close
of its donor conference that coastal
defense systems would be provided to the
ukrainians it is a good example how
working with allies and partners we are
successfully responding to ukraine's
requests
we expect additional new capabilities to
to be delivered in the near future
we can't always advertise what is being
delivered out of deference to our allies
and partners or for operational
sensitivities but we are moving with
speed and efficiency to deliver
let me close with this
even as russia acknowledges the failure
of its initial plans and shifts its
goals three elements of this war remain
constant
first russia will continue to use its
military to try to conquer and occupy
sovereign ukrainian territory second the
ukrainian military and people will
continue to effectively and bravely
defend their homeland and third the
united states will stand by them for as
long as it takes
russia has tried to subjugate the whole
of ukraine and it has failed
now it will attempt to bring parts of
the country under its rule
it may succeed in taking some territory
through sheer force and brutality but no
matter what happens over the coming
weeks it is clear that russia will never
be welcomed by the ukrainian people
instead its gains will be temporary as
the brave ukrainian people resist
russian occupation and carry on their
fight for an independent sovereign
nation that they so richly deserve and
with that i'd be happy to take your
questions yeah dave can i ask you about
the president's call for a war crimes
trial for vladimir putin
what are the mechanics of how the
president sees that playing out would it
be at the international criminal court
or in some
other so we have to consult with our
allies and partners on what makes most
sense as a mechanism moving forward
obviously the icc is one venue where war
crimes have been tried in the past but
there have been other examples in other
conflicts of other mechanisms being set
up so there's work to be done to work
out the specifics of that and between
now and then every day what we are
focused on is continuing to apply
pressure
to the russian economy and provide
weapons to the ukrainian people to be
able to defend themselves sorry forgive
me other other forums for this might
include something that the u.n general
does the u.n security council might
adopt is that what you're suggesting
well
obviously with russia as a permanent
member of the u.n security council
it would be difficult to imagine that
they would not attempt to exercise their
veto to block something
but there have been creative solutions
to the question of accountability in the
past and i'm not going to prejudge what
solution would be applied here or what
forum or venue would be applied here
what i will say is what the president
said this morning there has to be
accountability for these war crimes that
accountability has to be felt at every
level of the russian system and the
united states will work with the
international community to ensure that
accountability is applied at the
appropriate time yes
the president was careful to say he does
not see this as genocide many ukrainians
believe that it is because their nation
their people are being attacked where is
the line in your view and how have you
counseled the president between genocide
and war crimes so this is something we
of course continue to monitor every day
based on what we have seen so far we
have seen atrocities we have seen war
crimes we have not yet seen
a level of systematic
deprivation of life
of the ukrainian people to rise to the
level of genocide but again that's
something we will continue to monitor
there is not a mechanical formula for
this
there is a process that we have run just
recently at the state department to
ultimately determine that
uh the killing the mass killing of
rohingya in burma constituted genocide
that was a lengthy process based on an
amassing of evidence over a considerable
considerable period of time and
involving
frankly mass death uh the the
mass incarceration of a significant
portion of the rohingya population
and we will look to a series of
indicators along those lines to
ultimately make a determination in
ukraine but as the president said today
we have not arrived at that conclusion
yet yes thanks i just have three quick
questions when you say the next stage
will be protracted
do you mean years i mean russia has been
in crimea and gone bad since 2014.
what's protracted so we can't predict
but i would just say that so far this
conflict has lasted
a little more than five weeks and yet in
that time we've seen an enormous amount
of killing and death and also an
enormous amount of bravery and success
on the part of the ukrainian forces what
i'm saying when i say protracted is that
it may not be just a matter of a few
more weeks before all is said and done
that first quote unquote phase of the
conflict of the russians put it
was measured in weeks this next phase
could be measured in months or longer in
the beginning
the consensus seemed to be russia was
unstoppable we just had to make the
price as high as possible for them then
new thinking is maybe ukraine can
actually win
do you agree with that and what would
winning look like so we believe that our
job is to support the ukrainians they
will set the military objectives they
will set the objectives at the
bargaining table and i am quite certain
they are going to set those objectives
at success and we are going to give them
every tool we can to help them achieve
that success but we are not going to
define the outcome of this for the
ukrainians that is up for them to define
in us to support them in that's what
we're going to do and we do have
confidence in the bravery skill and
capacity of the ukrainian armed forces
and the resilience of the ukrainian
people one quick thing on chemical
weapons the president and other allies
have promised consequences without
saying what they would be
um last time russia used chemical
weapons there were sanctions but not
very stiff ones
are you ready to define consequences
so i'm going to say the same thing i've
said from this podium that the president
has said from a podium down the hall in
the same building which is that russia
will pay a severe price we have
communicated to them directly we have
coordinated with their allies and
partners and i'm not going to go further
in terms of the specifics here
the administration initially did not
call this war crimes and eventually they
did after what they saw on the ground do
you think that's going to be the case
with calling it a genocide
well so first it's not uh just that we
sit around and debate terms and then
ultimately decide to apply a term based
against static circumstances we watch as
things unfold we gather evidence
we continue to develop facts and as we
gathered evidence and as we
got the facts together we ultimately
came to the conclusion that war crimes
were committed and in fact i would say
on this front president biden was a
leader he went out and said putin is a
war criminal and many of you raised your
eyebrows at that many people
uh out in the public raise their
eyebrows at that and now you see the
scenes coming out of buchet today and so
he's not going to hesitate
to call a spade a spade to call it like
he sees it and neither is the us
government
so as the facts develop could we see
ourselves reaching a different
conclusion on that question of course we
could but it's going to be based on
evidence and facts as we gather it along
the way quick ones for you on the
sanctions that the president was talking
about today should we expect those this
week
or what's the timing you can expect
further sanctions announcements this
week and we are coordinating with our
allies and partners on what the exact
parameters of that will be but yes this
week we will have additional economic
pressure
elements to announce my last question
quickly you keep using the word retreat
instead of reposition
how much is that in part due to the
spring conditions the muddy conditions
that are on the ground in ukraine
the reason i use the phrase retreat uh
is just kind of quite simple common
sense it's not some fancy technical
military term it's a term that all of us
understand which is if you run pell mel
for an objective and you get stopped and
then you start to get beaten back and
then you withdraw you pull out that's
what i would call a retreat that's what
happened to the russians and eve they
attacked kiev they failed they started
to get
beaten backwards by the russian by the
ukrainian military and they ultimately
retreated back across the border into
belarus now
with those forces as i said in my
opening comments they are not intending
to stand pat they are going to
reposition those forces
to go after a different objective a
scaled down objective but nonetheless a
dangerous and disturbing objective which
is to conquer and occupy territory in
eastern ukraine and now it's our job to
help the ukrainian people have the tools
they need to be able to stymie that
objective that is what we're intent on
doing at this stage thank you i know
you're not willing to call it a a
genocide but does the us government have
information that you can
that you can use to independently
corroborate ukraine's allegations about
atrocities in lukaku
so we have uh obviously got access to a
lot of the information that you all have
we also have information that the
ukrainians have provided us directly and
we will also work with fact finders
independent fact finders as we go
forward to get to a level of
documentation
that allows us to help build very strong
dossiers of evidence for war crimes
prosecutions and that is what we intend
to do now on the question of the
genocide determination obviously we will
continue on a daily basis to have
consultations with ukrainians uh to
reach determinations and if at some
point we've reached the judgment uh that
there in fact has been a level of
atrocity a level of killing a level
of
intentional activity that rises to meet
our definition of genocide we'll call it
for what it is we have never hesitated
to call out the russians for what they
have done in ukraine and we will not
start now
on france uh jake uh they are uh they've
suggested uh that you know a a hefty eu
wide tariff should be imposed as opposed
to a blanket ban on uh russian energy
imports into the eu does the us support
that and will that be part of
what you're planning to do next in terms
of sanctions we are having uh
conversations as i stand here at this
podium with senior officials in
the main european capitals as well as in
brussels on the full range of sanctions
options including sanctions options or
pressure options that relate to energy
i'm not going to negotiate that out at
this podium we want to make sure that
we're able to pull together a consensus
along with the rest of the european
union the kremlin is denying the images
out of bucha saying that they don't show
any kind of apparent execution
what is the us doing to try and expose
russia's actions to its own citizens i
mean what can we do to sort of fight
this information war
well first i would note that
the kremlin is working overtime to close
down the information space inside of
russia which is not exactly
the action of a strong and confident
government that feels really good about
the story that
it would be telling if it were allowing
independent news sources to come in
second
we are of course supporting through a
variety of means the provision of
information about
these atrocities and about the entire
effort by the russians to unjustly and
unlawfully invade a sovereign
neighboring country not just to the
russian people but to people everywhere
we will continue to do that
is it your sense that
the atrocities that we're seeing in
bucha are based on orders coming from
putin or his senior military officials
or is there a chance here that this is
sort of russian forces acting on their
own and is there even a distinction i
don't want to get into
the specific intelligence related to
bucha at this point but what i will say
as i said at the outset
is even before the invasion happened
we shared information with the public
with the press including from this
podium
that russia was intending as a matter of
policy not as a matter of one guy in a
unit
in a suburb of kiev but as a matter of
policy in this war to kill dissidents to
kill those who caused problems for the
occupation
and to impose a reign of terror across
occupied territories within ukraine that
is what we are seeing play out so no we
do not believe that this is just a
random accident
or the rogue act of a particular
individual we believe that this was part
of the plan
we declared it
from
this podium as part of the plan and now
we're seeing it play out in real life in
living color in these terrible tragic
images we are seeing come from bucha
yeah thanks um i know you don't want to
talk about possible venues for a war
trial work on trial but can you talk a
little bit about the evidence gathering
aspect of it that's that's going to be
crucial to combating disinformation and
um what russians will say that you know
ukrainian rebels are are fighting us
that was legitimate warfare what
happened that could be a tactic they're
taking so can you walk us through
the evidence gathering who's doing it
other people on the ground gathering
evidence how long does that take to sort
of build a case and what does that look
like
so i will directly answer your question
but i also think it is important
for
our team at the state department which
will take the lead on this including our
global war crimes coordinator to give
you a fully elaborate answer to this
question in technical detail so that
everybody understands exactly how this
process works but
with that being said there are four main
sources of information that we will
develop in an effort to help build the
case for war crimes the first is the
information we and our allies and
partners gather including through
intelligent sources and we actually
within our intelligence community
had previously stood up a team to be
able to document and analyze war crimes
and work closely with the state
department in doing so we're also
coordinating with key allies and
partners who have their own capacities
the second is what the ukrainians
themselves will do on the ground to
develop this case
to document the forensics uh of these
tragic and senseless killings in this
particular instance and in other
instances across ukraine
the third is uh international
organizations
uh including the united nations but
others as well uh
prominent international non-governmental
organizations with real credibility and
expertise in this area and then the
fourth is all of you
because part of building this case is
relying upon the global independent
media
who has images interviews documentation
and when you put all of those four
sources together you can build we
believe a package that can stand up to
the relentless disinformation we are
likely to see and have already started
seeing from russia and that ultimately
the truth will withstand the assault on
the truth that we can uh expect to come
from moscow
on former president trump he's having
save america rallies where he's decrying
the biden administration decrying the
response that you will in the white
house have been given to this war in
ukraine he said if he was in here in
office he would do it better it wouldn't
happen under him what is your response
to the former president donald j trump
saying these things about the current
administration i don't have a response
to the former president we are focused
on getting the job done getting the
support to the ukrainian people that
they need and applying unprecedented
pressure to the russian economy and
building a form of western unity that no
one could reasonably have expected and
that we have sustained through the early
weeks of the war and will sustain for
the period ahead and i'll leave the
commentary on what the former president
said to others
very much thanks jake to follow up on
what you said about ukraine setting
terms for any potential resolution
president zielinski um said on face the
nation that
with regard to any potential peace
agreement the important thing in this
agreement are security guarantees but he
also said the u.s has not
received has not provided any yet is the
u.s considering that and what would that
look like
so we are in regular contact and by
regular i mean near daily contact i
personally am in near daily contact with
my counterpart in the ukrainian
government
and we are talking constantly about how
we can support
a negotiated solution that that
defends ukraine's sovereignty and
territorial integrity and we have told
them that we are prepared to do our part
to support that including by ensuring
that ukraine has the means to defend
itself in the future
i'm not going to get into the specifics
of what those negotiations are because i
believe it's very important that they
have a protected space to be able to be
carried out but you can rest assured
that the united states is actively
working
in consultation with ukrainians to
support their efforts at the peace table
and then a question on the sanctions uh
you just said that you're under no
illusions that russia will adjust its
target so
what function will an additional
sanctions package have
when you announce it so i would say two
things about sanctions one is that uh
sanctions are intended to impose costs
so that russia cannot carry on these
grotesque acts without paying a severe
price for it the other is to have an
effect on russia's behavior over time
but as president biden has made clear
repeatedly we don't expect that
that shift in behavior will be caused by
sanctions overnight or in a week it will
take time to grind down
the uh elements of russian power within
the russian economy to hit their
industrial base hard to hit the sources
of revenue uh that have propped up this
war and propped up the kleptoc
kleptocracy in russia that's going to
take some time to play out but there's
no better time than now to be working at
that so that the costs end up setting in
and that ends up sharpening russia's
choices so sanctions are not alone
going to solve any of these problems but
they are a critical tool in ultimately
producing a better outcome to this
conflict than it would otherwise be
how the revelations about bucha
prompted the administration and its
allies to reconsider what kind of
military assistance did you run in
ukraine are tanks now part of you know
potential transfers that could be
provided to the ukraine military
so i'm not going to get into certain
specific systems because as i said at
the outset there are operational
sensitivities and the sensitivities of
our allies and partners for why we
wouldn't speak
about a particular capability like tanks
but i will say this even before bucha
the united states was working with
ukrainians
on
every item on its priority list
and how we could go ahead and ensure
that that could be provided to them uh
the only uh capability that we have
discussed with them where there has been
a difference in perspective that has
been played out in living color in this
podium many times over has been the
question of direct facilitation from a
u.s air base in germany in the contested
airspace over ukraine and mig-29s
otherwise before bucha we were working
with them on a wide range of
capabilities including some capabilities
that people here were writing we weren't
prepared to provide that wasn't right
now it's hard for me to correct the
record in every case because
for very good reasons
some of these systems we cannot
advertise we cannot talk to you all
about but what i would want to make
clear is
the extent and depth of effort to
acquire and transfer
uh a variety of advanced weapons
capabilities
is extraordinary it is unprecedented and
it has been ongoing from well before the
terrible images came out the
international criminal court it's one of
the reasons why the u.s is visiting
alternate venues because the u.s is not
a signatory and does that undercut the
u.s push to hold putin accountable uh
with the war crimes trial of some kind
when the u.s is not the signatory of the
international criminal court the u.s has
in the past been able to collaborate
with the international criminal court in
other contexts but despite not being a
signatory but there's a variety of
reasons one might consider alternative
venues as well beyond the specific
relationship between the us and the icc
most importantly this is not a decision
the united states is going to make by
itself we're not going to make the call
out of washington for the appropriate
venue for accountability that is going
to be done
in consultation with allies and with
partners around the world and i don't
want to prejudge those conversations
they're ongoing
and uh what i can communicate is the
very real
uh sustained and committed
uh proposition that the united states
has that we are going to ensure that
there is accountability yes i'll just
take one
the u.s had rejected poland's plan for a
peacekeeping force to protect civilians
is that something that's being
reconsidered given what we've seen of
these atrocities and is there any talk
among the allies to do some sort of
force that will protect the civilian
population so i don't quite accept the
the premise of the question uh there
there have been various peacekeeping
proposals floated none of them have ever
been given full shape or been kind of
formally put forward and suggested
should actually be implemented and so we
continue to consult with our allies and
partners including poland on what makes
sense going forward
we have not yet seen a proposal that
actually has been fleshed out that could
be operationalized
the one thing that the united states has
made clear throughout this is that it is
not our intention to send u.s soldiers
to fight russian soldiers in ukraine but
in terms of the supply of capabilities
in terms of other steps to support the
ukrainians uh and to do our best to
protect civilians in ukraine we continue
to look at every possible option
including in consultation with our
partners on that
he will i'm sure he's he's probably our
most frequent to guest i don't know if
you get i probably owe him something for
that um
okay a couple of items for all of you at
the top uh today vice president harris
and administration officials announced
the biden harris action plan for
building a better school infrastructure
by leveraging funds from the bipartisan
infrastructure law and the american
rescue plan this action plan will
activate the entire federal government
to support students health and learning
from upgraded hvac systems to electric
school buses from on-site solar energy
installations to safe routes to school
also wanted to note in light of the
president's event on trucking a couple
of details or facts for all of you
2021 was the best year for trucking
growth uh jobs growth since 1994 and
december 2021 through february of 2022
was the best three-month stretch for
long-distance truck hiring since the
1990s thanks to the efforts of the
department of transportation we doubled
the issuance of commercial driver's
license issuances in january and
february 2022 compared to the prior
january and february of 2021 and over
100 employers including domino's
frito-lay and ups launched registered
apprenticeship programs in the past 90
days this could result in more than 10
10 000 additional apprentices and
apprenticeships nationwide which of
course get more people
more truckers trained more trucks on the
road more goods moving around and onto
shelves across the country
also wanted to note i think we you all
saw this but just to confirm for all of
you tomorrow the president and vice
president will be joined by former
president obama to highlight how the
affordable care act continues to lower
health care costs for american families
this will be the first time former
president obama returns to the white
house since leaving office
since we've taken office since we've
ended president since president biden
has entered office we've taken big steps
to reduce health care costs and expand
access to health care for uh the
american people and how president biden
and for former president obama both see
the affordable care act is
an example a shining example of how
government can work for the american
people not only did it ensure that
millions of people had access to
affordable health care but it isn't has
been an opportunity to build on that and
make changes and make improvements over
the course of time which of course is
what they will talk about tomorrow but
even since the president took office
through the american rescue plan we
lowered premiums for nine million
americans the biggest expansion of
affordable healthcare since the aca
we've made affordable health coverage
more accessible during the pandemic
through the opening of the special
enrollment period which enabled nearly 3
million americans to
have access to to newly sign up for
coverage under the aca and president uh
biden has overseen the most successful
open enrollment his period in history
last year with a historic 14.5 million
americans
signing up for the for aca coverage and
another million people signing up for
the basic uh health care program so
tomorrow they'll announce more steps
i'll also note as they did every week
when president former president obama
was president and president biden was
vice president that's a mouthful
they will have lunch tomorrow as well as
they used to do on a weekly basis i
would note they continue to talk
regularly they are real friends not just
washington friends and so i'm sure they
will talk about events in the world as
well as their families and personal
lives so i'll try to get around the room
as best as i can but chris why don't you
kick us off uh so one question on title
42 uh some republican attorney general
are suing the administration over trying
to lift it uh what is the
administration's response um and
administration concerns this would have
blocking
the push to lift the order well on the
lawsuit itself i'd of course refer you
to the department of justice they would
be overseeing any steps there but
broadly speaking i think it's important
to note
for any critics and any lawsuits
that title 42 is a public health
directive it's not an immigration
migration enforcement measure and the
decision on when to lift title 42 was
made by the cdc and our objective from
here and this is why we have the
implementation period over the next
several weeks continues to be to uh
ensure we are increasing our
our resources surging personnel and
resources to the border improving border
processing implementing covet 19
mitigation
measures and continuing to work with
other countries in the western
hemisphere to manage migration and
address root causes but this is again a
health care measure a health measure uh
determination and not one not an
immigration policy go ahead thanks jen
let me ask you the question i was going
to ask jake which is that as part of
this new effort to ramp up sanctions or
is the administration going to be
ramping up pressure on china and india
to abide by existing sanctions and and
what does that look like under the leap
signatures in india are you going to
intensify some criticism of them and
others who haven't done so well well
certainly our expectation um and our
public and private message is will
continue to be that every country should
abide by the sanctions that we have
announced and that we are implementing
around the world as you noted so let me
start with india if that's okay as you
noted
dilip singer deputy national security
advisor
was just there
i would note that you know just given
some of the reporting
energy payments are not sanctioned
that's a decision made by each
individual country and we've been very
clear that each country is going to make
their own choices even as we have made
the decision and other countries have
made the decision to ban energy imports
uh what uh what
did make clear
to his counterparts during this visit
was that we don't believe it's in
india's interest to accelerate or
increase imports of russian energy and
other commodities
right now just to give everybody the
full scope of it india's imports of
russian energy represent only one to two
percent
of their total energy imports so uh
while he als he explained both the
mechanisms of our sanctions and
reiterated that any country or entities
should be abiding by those we also made
clear that we'd be happy to be a partner
in reducing their reliance or even their
small percentage of uh of reliance on
that uh as it relates to china i know
that jake spoke to this the last time he
was here
our assessment hasn't changed on that
front but we continue to
convey the same expectations of abiding
by sanctions
token funding the reports that the
republicans and democrats in the senate
are nearing a deal on a 10 billion
package that doesn't include global aid
is a package of that size and that
doesn't include a global vaccine
assistance something that president
obama could sign us a lot well let me
first say uh that we are encouraged by
the strong progress that congress is
making and finalizing a deal not yet
final but finalizing a deal to fund some
of our most uh very urgent coveted
response
needs uh i would remind everyone that
what we had requested was 22.5 billion
not 10 billion in order to
achieve a number of objectives including
securing enough booster shots for the
general population purchasing more
monoclonal antibodies and evasheld for
the immune immunocompromise maintaining
our testing capacity getting shocked in
arms abroad to go to your question and
funding for variant specific vaccines if
needed so this does not will obviously
not meet all of those all of those needs
dire needs in this country
and certainly our objective would
continue be to be to press for funding
for uh international uh support for
international for ensuring we continue
to be the arsenal vaccines in the world
uh regardless of what this final package
looks like i'd note that the reason
that's so important is not just
because of the need to have vaccine
doses it's because we need to a lot of
there are countries around the world who
are refusing our vaccine doses because
they don't have the mechanisms the
know-how and the capacity to be able to
distribute those doses so that funding
that we've been requesting we'll
continue to press for uh would be
accounting for that as well i can i know
one more last thing sorry i've got a lot
on this um is i would also note
that as you're watching congress in the
senate there are a wide number of
republicans who have called for
uh funding for and called for ensuring
that we continue to be uh the arsenal of
vaccine distribution around the world
they don't use that exact phrase but
basically that's the basics
including senator graham who said i
support the effort just in june of last
year of the biden administration did
jonat date vaccines to at-risk
populations throughout the world
senator portman said
that that he is pleased that legislation
this is last summer that has passed that
the committee at the time uh would help
ensure that that domestic supply is part
of our what we're doing in domestic
access domestic supply is part of our
global vaccination strategy strategy
senator mcconnell said it would be
terribly unfortunate if a supplemental
coven 19 funding package did not include
international vaccines so i'm not going
to prejudge where all they they will all
be on this or future legislation i would
just note that if we want to continue to
be uh providing to the world we need
money and that's a case we will continue
to make go ahead uh ukraine prosecutor
general just suggested that there's more
gruesome evidence of the aftermath of
russia's occupation around keith um
saying that the worst situation may in
fact be in borodanka i apologize but i
don't pronounce that correctly but do
you have a sense of how widespread this
may be in the region i mean i know jake
just said that you're going to continue
to see these kinds of brazen attacks but
what more can you tell us about some of
these other areas that we may be hearing
about i don't have a new or additional
assessment this is something we will
continue to gather information on and
jake obviously outlined the number of
ways we will do that both by intel
gathering working with our
partners and allies around the world um
but i would also know mary to go back to
your earlier question that uh the fact
that we're seeing these uh horrific
images from bucha around the world you
know now around the world thanks to all
of your broadcasts and many global
broadcasters i mean we have access
there's access to this area there's not
access to a lot of the areas around
mariopol and other areas of ukraine
where we have not even begun to see the
impact of the atrocities and the impact
of what as jake said
president putin and the russians made
clear they were intending to do from the
outside of the war so uh while i don't
have additional assessment i would just
note that um you know we should brace
ourselves for what we may see as we gain
greater access and learn more about what
atrocities they've implemented go ahead
thank you
this ambassador to the un says that
tomorrow she's going to go to new york
and seek russia's suspension from the
human rights council is that the
direction of the president yes the
president does not believe uh he
believes it's ludicrous uh for russia to
be a member of the human rights council
and certainly i i the ambassador spoke
to this today and uh while she was on
her overseas trip and she will continue
to make the case uh in her role when she
returns to new york why not seek to
permanently expel them
from the human rights council
i would point it i would point you to
our u.n ambassador on what specific
steps but obviously removing them uh
would be the next appropriate step in
the process
um
thank you jen so president biden is
talking about putting putin on a wartime
trial does he expect putin to turn
himself in to stand trial or does he
think somebody's going to have to go
into russia and arrest him
well without getting into the mechanisms
which i know were the good questions
everybody was asking uh our national
security advisor there is precedent in
the past of how this process can work
we're not going to prejudge what the
process would work or
or uh what steps uh would be taken uh
through the through an international
legal process so that's not quite where
we're at right now peter and i can't
give you a sense of the mechanisms of of
if if convicted what would happen okay a
question about college sports in some
places like the ivy league now
there are biological males competing
against women does the white house think
that is fair
well i would note that we're not the
governing body for the ncaa or uh any
other
system out there that i believe you're
probably referring to
the case over in in swimming in the ncaa
we understand how important sports are
to student athletes across the country
but the ncaa obviously makes
puts these policies in place
what i would say uh peter if we look at
this broadly is that we celebrated
international transgender day of
visibility last week with a slate of new
actions to ensure we are continuing uh
we continue to protect the dignity and
identity of all americans and at a
moment uh where we're looking at and
we're seeing increased mental health
issues related to young people
especially lgbtq plus young people we're
providing additional funding and
resources to address this issue and we
hope all leaders can focus on
those important issues and the impact on
many of these young people who are are
impacted across the country and then
what about this new law in florida at
what age does the white house think that
students should be taught about sexual
orientation and gender identity
well i i would say uh first of all peter
um we have spoken to uh the don't say
gay bill in the past i believe is what
you're referring to and made clear that
as we look at this
this
this law
what we think it's a reflection of is
politicians in florida propagating
misinformed hateful policies that do
absolutely nothing to address
the real issues the department of
education is well positioned and ready
to evaluate um what to do next and uh
when and its implementation whether this
implementation violates federal civil
rights law uh but i would note that
parents across the country are looking
to um you know
national state and district leaders to
support our nation's students to ensure
that
kids are treated equally in schools and
that is certainly not this is not a
reflection of that and so just the last
one so if you guys oppose this law that
bans classroom instruction about
sexual orientation and gender identity
in k-3
does white house support that kind of
classroom instruction before
kindergarten do you have examples of
schools in uh florida that are teaching
kindergarteners about sex education
asking for the president i think that's
a i think that's a relevant question
because i think this is a politically
charged
harsh law that is putting
parents and lgbtq plus kids in a very
difficult uh a heartbreaking
circumstance and so i actually think
that's a pretty relevant question go
ahead on the ukraine atrocities
jake referenced some of the images that
all our news organizations have been
gathering
is the administration able to gather
other and document other cases that you
have assembled that we may not be aware
of in terms of this collection of data
on
war crimes
rapes murders things like that that we
have not yet seen is there more on the
ground you mean so i i'm sure you've
seen kelly that the eu announced their
intention to send a team there which
obviously hasn't happened yet but that
was an announcement made earlier today
certainly through intel gathering we
likely do have access to different types
of information we've declassified a
range of information over the course of
time which i would expect we continue to
do we will continue to do
right now i can't give you an assessment
of what we may know that you don't know
but i would just say and reiterate what
jake said which is we're going to use
every tool at our disposal we can some
of that is through intel channels some
of that is of course working with our
counterparts around the world to gather
as much data and information as we can
it is difficult to go back to an earlier
question given that
we need access or even our european
friends and partners need access to
gather but but it is it is vital it is
important and we are going to do
everything we can to support those
efforts from here and if the uh russians
are able to take uh some territory in
the east and have greater stability of
their control there
would it ever be the u.s position that
that could be a stable outcome
or is maintaining the current map of
ukrainian sovereignty what the west
would want sure well it's going to be up
to the ukrainians and ukrainian leaders
to determine uh what the diplomatic path
forward looks like here uh what
discussions what negotiations they are
comfortable with what our objective is
and what what tool we can we feel we can
most be effective at i should say is
supporting them and strengthening their
hand in these negotiations and that
includes not just the economic support
the military
support i would note over the course of
the last couple of days the department
of defense announced an additional
package it beyond what was announced
just a few weeks ago so we're going to
continue to do that but in terms of the
negotiations and what they would be
comfortable with we're here to support
them and we're not going to predetermine
that go ahead um thanks jen um just last
week uh you said that uh the us's uh
sending a protective gear to ukraine to
help uh ship ukrainians from chemical uh
weapons use um have those deliveries
been made or have they started is there
any timeline specifically for those
deliveries because jay good mentions
that deliveries has started sure i can
check for you a status of that we try to
do it in an expedited manner and we
still have means of getting equipment of
a range of equipment uh two people who
need it on the ground and i can check if
that equipment has been delivered or is
in process i guess right yeah and i have
a quick question on on elon musk and him
picking up a nine percent stake in
twitter which makes him the largest
shareholder in the company obviously the
white house uses twitter quite
extensively
and musk has been very critical of
president biden i'm wondering if there
is perhaps any recalibration of the use
of the platform or to what extent you
know the white house is using twitter
uh that's a decision of a private sector
leader i don't have any specific comment
on it but i expect we will continue to
use twitter as as you all will as well i
would expect um go ahead thanks jim i i
was wondering if you could elaborate a
little bit more on president biden and
former president obama and their
relationship and how often and how they
communicate
and you mentioned that they are real
friends and not just washington friends
but given that they only live a few
miles apart why is this the first time
that the former president has been
invited to the white house
well i would say um first i have known
them both for some time
and i've watched i watched their
friendship
grow over the course of uh the period of
time when the president was vice
president and when the former president
was president and uh why i noted that at
the top is because i think people who
didn't have the seat i had uh may just
think that it's like inviting any former
president to the white house and it
certainly is not that they talk on the
phone uh they do that on a regular basis
i'm not going to give you the number of
times they've had conversations but i
would note they consult on a range of
issues uh but also about their families
and things happening in their personal
lives and uh you know it's not a
relationship of obligation it's one
where they developed a deep and close
friendship through the course of their
time serving together and that has
continued um and tomorrow is of course
exactly the right time to have the
former president uh come here given this
is one of the proudest accomplishments
that they worked on together they shared
together and it is emblematic of their
shared view and belief that government
can work for people and it can work for
the american people and this is an
example of building on a success from
more than 10 years ago and making it
better over time so and i i i suspect
that former president obama will be back
when there is a uh a portrait unveiling
and perhaps for other other engagements
here as well in the future go ahead
karen thanks jen can you tell us how the
president or president engaged with
lawmakers in the last couple of days on
the coveted funding deal and you talked
to any republicans on this
i'm not going to give you an outline or
a detail of people he's spoken to
i will note that it's rare that i am in
the oval office on any given day where
he doesn't just pick up the phone and
call
a member of congress often a republican
at least when i'm in there
to talk to them about a range of
priorities this is clearly a huge
focus for the president
because of the dire need we have at this
moment to get this funding through and
the fact that we are
already at a point where we have had to
halt delay a range of programs and
purchases that
we feel are imperative i would note that
on the global side
you know we are
we already need to stop plans to explain
expand the global vaccination initiative
to more countries we'll also have to
immediately scale back our global
efforts to provide
life-saving tools this is a little bit
of what i mentioned earlier like oxygen
systems antiviral pills things that can
cut death rates
by 90 percent for the unvaccinated and i
would also note that even as we're very
encouraged by the progress we're going
to need more because our objective here
is going to continue to be uh to be
ahead of the process and be ahead in
planning to make sure we can have
funding for antivirals the the vaccines
needed for uh for um people for for many
uh months to come
so he has been talking on this specific
issue he's been engaged with a range of
members about a range of issues this is
a huge priority i'm just not going to
get into the details of what those calls
look like go ahead thanks jen i just
wanted to clarify um on what i was
asking jake here because it sounded like
at the end he was leaving open the
possibility of u.s boots on the ground
to protect civilians in ukraine or to
protect the supply i don't think that
was his intention
he did say in terms of the supply chain
or civilians that you're discussing all
possibilities with allies
we nothing has changed about the
president's view about boots on the
ground
all right
so um the jobs report came out on friday
um inflation is at 7.9 percent it shows
uh average hourly wages went up 5.6
i wonder what the level of concern is
for the president of the white house
that people will stop spending because
the stuff they want is more expensive
and that leads us to a recession
well i would say on the on the latter
part of your question that um what we
know is that um the economy is strong
our recovery has been strong uh and that
continues to be well we only of course
are monitoring progress and where we
have concern including
rising costs and obviously the need to
continue to address inflation
that continues to be
our assessment which is which is even as
there are challenges we need to continue
to address
means that we have a strong basis that
we were building from i would remind you
also that
the unemployment rate is 3.6 percent um
and the president created more jobs last
year than any president in american
history so those fundamentals are also
backed up by data
and obviously what we're trying to do as
you know from following this closely
there are a couple of areas that are
impacting rising costs more than others
right including the price of gas
including
the price of automobiles and the impacts
on the car industry of the lack of the
chip shortages so we're also trying to
do is take steps to address each area
where we see rising costs and obviously
the president's announcement on thursday
to do a historic release from the
strategic petroleum reserve where we've
seen already a small reduction in the
price of gas and the price of oil come
down by several dollars is an effort to
bring down costs that are impacting
people's checkbook pocketbooks checkbook
et cetera
we of course continue to assess but i
don't have any projection of that at
this point in time one thing on the
wealth test uh elon musk tweeted out
last week that uh tesla and spacex would
have died if such attacks existed in
2008 after the great recession um with
the push for evs and space exploration
what's the white house level of concern
that that a wealth tax could stifle
innovation
well i would first say that you know
right now
america's teachers and firefighters pay
a higher tax rate than billionaires i
don't even think elon musk probably
thinks that's fair i don't know who
thinks that's fair it's not fair um and
that should not be the case and so what
this proposal does and why the president
supports it in his view is it fixes that
and this would close an unfair tax
loophole and promote economic growth by
encouraging productivity enhancing
investments and really what it does to
get into the nitty-gritty of it is you
know right now the super wealthy
billionaires i think everyone considers
them super wealthy are able to access
the value of their assets even if they
never sell them in order to finance uh
lavish consumption right now
billionaires with unrealized gains
borrow against their assets during uh
light their life at ultra low interest
rates and when when they die they get a
step up in basis and no taxes paid on
the appreciation of their asset in other
words their income is never taxed that's
not fair and i think what the
president's trying to do and what many
senators and others support is closing
that uh why that should impact a lack of
innovation i think there should be more
explanation on this is trying to make
the system more fair go ahead oh sorry
we shall come back to you
thank you
18 u.s senators i've meeting president
biden urging him to
designate cameroon for tps is that
something he's willing to do uh that's
an assessment is made by a process led
by the department of homeland security
so i don't have any prediction of that
at this point and on his
approval rating when he came into office
last year he was around 60
and even more and now he's around 40
percent and sometimes less who does he
blame now putin trump for you
the communication oh is it like me oh i
don't know um i hope not um look i i
think that um the president recognizes
that um the country is still grappling
with a number of challenges that impact
people in their everyday lives uh
whether that is a continuing fight uh
with a pandemic that has been going on
for several years or the fact that costs
are going up some of those are result of
the actions of president putin yes as it
relates to gas prices
but others are related to impacts of
covet 19 and impacts on the supply chain
so what our focus is and his focus
continues to be on
solutions to address these challenges
and uh keeping our heads down and trying
to continue to deliver for the american
people go ahead weisha
shifting to russian billionaires because
today the doj announced the seizure of
that yes huge 90 million yacht um
is there any evidence that zoning in on
trees close allies in this way seizing
their assets is having an impact on his
calculations
and if not what is the
end goal here to try to apply pressure
to putin themselves
well i think it's not the only approach
we're taking right wija but it is one of
the steps that we have our national
security team determined from the
beginning
would hopefully be effective on
putting necessary pressure on
that includes significant consequences
we have implemented on the russian
economy
but it also includes
going after
people who are in the inner circle and
are close uh where their actions have
warranted um that including russian
oligarchs uh but it is not our
our expectation is not that one
component is going to lead to a direct
change these are just a range of
pressure points and we're going to use
all of them that we possibly can so what
is the hope that this particular action
will take because we're seeing so many
images
of yachts around the world being seized
other assets being seized well again
it's one of several actions we're taking
and i think if you look at the totality
of it and the pool of the actions the
russian economy uh has been on a
downward spiral um there are businesses
private sector businesses around the
world have pulled their their uh their
business and their investments out of
russia they are isolated from the world
uh the oligarchs are isolated from the
world all of these are meant to be
consequences and meant to of course
impact the calculation over the longer
term
one quickly on the president's
announcement last week
about the uh
strategic supply of oil yep so
you know
the crude prices came down and saw that
almost right away but how long
do you expect
that band-aid will hold
if opec does not also agree to ramp up
production which it has not so far
well here's how you should look at it it
was intentionally done
as a million uh barrels a day over the
course of six months
because we knew there needed to be kind
of a gap filled for that period of time
where expectation and hope is that there
could be greater production by the oil
companies over that course of time
there are also steps as you've seen this
is a coordinated release around the
world and there was an announcement last
friday about that as well
by other countries to help
fill the gap that we we see
from russia and from the fact that their
uh oil is not contributing as much as it
had historically onto the global
marketplace and obviously oil prices are
are global i mean it's a global
marketplace um so we're already seeing
as you said a reduction but this is
meant to be a six-month uh effort to uh
to kind of bridge the gap in many ways
for that period of time and ramp up
production in a range of ways yes you
referenced opec plus but also other
countries
last friday announced their plans and
their intentions to release more oil to
help meet the supply needs on the market
that's what we're intending to do here
and we're going to continue to look at
many ways to achieve that objective go
ahead uh iran over the weekend said that
the deal was close we heard something
different from u.s officials only days
before that so what is the current
assessment of that deal
well our assessment is that the onus for
concluding this deal is squarely on iran
together with our european allies the
united states has negotiated the road
map for a mutual return to compliance
through the vienna talks the president
will reenter the deal if it's in our
national security interest in both
ourselves and our allies
are prepared to conclude a strong
agreement if iran is prepared to do the
same what we've seen however is that
iran has raised a number of issues that
has nothing to do
with the mutual compliance under the
nuclear deal and uh that is where our
focus and our objectives is so we would
encourage iran to focus on the deal
negotiated in vienna rather than seeking
to open issues outside the vienna
context or casting blame of course on
others for a pause in the talk is the
white house making any push this week
last minute push to get another
republican or two to support judge
jackson and and secondly if you could
reflect on what uh senator graham said
about uh if republicans were in control
that she wouldn't get a hearing
uh well let me stay on the first part
that our view continues to be that judge
jackson's credentials uh her
record uh warrant bipartisan support uh
we've seen some of that to date but
certainly we're going to continue to
work the phones uh up until the last
moment uh here but i can't make you a
prediction for you on what the end
result of that uh will be uh i would say
on senator graham's uh comments i i
think the best questions are probably
posed to senator graham i would remind
you all that he has previously voted for
judge jackson uh when her record and her
credentials were exactly the same as
they are today so seems like there's
more questions that could be posed to
him go ahead as a follow-up on the
senate supreme court confirmation
hearing
republicans have said that they wanted
to this this would be a respectful and
fair process and it's been very
contentious
given senator graham's comments
what do you think is the nature of the
supreme court as we look ahead uh for
future not just this supreme court
nominee but for future nominations given
the the contentious comments from
senator graham
uh well look i i think that our view
continues to be that qualified nominees
those who meet every objective bar of
qualification of backgrounds
should be considered
and treated with fairness as they go
through the process
um that's how president biden is going
to continue to
to
operate and that's how we would expect
every
member of the senate uh to continue to
operate so
obviously his comments are disappointing
but our focus needs to continue to be on
uh on supporting uh judge jackson and uh
and her uh path to the supreme court
go ahead jen i wanted to ask two
questions one about refugees and what
about the supreme court sure on refugees
the hundred thousand number that the
president put out when you all were in
europe yeah can you talk about how you
arrived at that number and if what
preparations are being made at this
point to accept those refugees i haven't
seen the state department really put out
a lot of detail yet yeah i i expect
we'll have more soon and i think the
understandable questions are kind of the
prioritization and how the process will
work and what the models will be all
very good questions and we're just
working through the final pieces of the
policy process at this point in time in
terms of the number it doesn't mean we
will we will reach that number as you
know that while there have been uh
a startling number of refugees
individuals who have been kicked out of
their homes because of the russian
invasion of ukraine the vast majority of
them want to stay in neighboring
countries and that continues to be our
expectation but this is just an effort
for us to play a role beyond the the uh
historic amount of his uh humanitarian
assistance and support we're providing
to neighboring countries uh to uh ensure
that we can find a pathway for those who
want to come to the united states to
come here too but uh we're still
finalizing the policy details and
hopefully we'll have more soon on that
for you
one more on the supreme court yeah
president biden was asked last week
about clarence justice clarence thomas
um
i believe he said something or he said
it was up to the justice department or
the january 6th committee on whether
justice clarence thomas would recuse
himself from any of those cases those
being the january 6 cases
judicial ethics mean that the supreme
court or justice generally makes his own
decision on recusals does the president
still agree with the view of the justice
department or january 6th committee
should decide has he taken a position at
this point on whether justice thomas
should recuse himself
that's a decision up to the supreme
court we don't have an additional
position from here go ahead
they were friends from the time they
were on foreign relations committee
together
so
um in terms of
japan has largest number of u.s troops
is there some way that they could be
involved as a country that also went
through war with this current situation
in russia and you know if they've been
included in
some of these discussions going forward
i know that um that they have been
included in a part of the conversations
including during president biden's
recent trip to europe and that uh our
partnership and friendship uh with japan
uh continues as we discuss how to help
support uk crane uh through the invasion
uh russia's invasion go ahead
i mean the ukraine crisis we know united
states and russia still working together
on afghanistan issues actually last
thursday march 31st there's a meeting in
china where the u.s china and russia
delegations
over this issue can you describe the
working relations between us and russia
on this on this meeting and what's
china's role on it do you worry china
might take advantage of the tension
between the us and russia right now
and just do i make sure i'm unpacking
your question what you're asking about
you're asking about a meeting on
afghanistan between russian u.s and f
and um i'm sorry chinese officials
i would really point to the state
department i'm happy to get more details
on it and see i would note that uh
russia and china are both members of the
p5 plus one and obviously we're
continuing to pursue a diplomatic deal
uh there as well um so there are other
examples of us working
even as we are horrified by the
atrocities in ukraine okay last one
thank you
moments ago you said that it was
ludicrous that russia would be allowed
to sit on the u.n human rights council
i'm wondering if the president wants to
see china remain on the human rights
council as well given that his
administration has already made a
determination that china's engaged in
genocide against the uyghur people
our focus right now on the international
stage on this question is on russia
given
the invasion of ukraine and given what
we're seeing the photos from bhusha
others that we may see in the future
obviously we will continue to press
publicly and privately where we have
concerns about human rights violations
including as it relates to china thanks
so much everyone